we're gonna pull adam west out of the
past and shove his beautiful innocent
little body into the trailer for the new
batman
no one's okay we're doing something very
different than all the other videos
we've done to this point
so the new batman's out we've all seen
it at this point right in theaters i
love the movie too i watched the whole
thing yeah
all the way through wow yeah well that's
good that's big for you i never left the
theater
once i never walked out oh my gosh i'm
proud of you man yeah do you guys think
that like this is the most gritty take
on batman that we've seen yeah he's
pretty emo he's pretty yeah yeah yeah
like full blown eye makeup but and it's
not like clean either it's smudgy oh and
that's how you know much smudgy eyeballs
yeah that's who batman's supposed to be
batman is gritty batman is this tortured
soul who's navigated life without
parents it's violent it's gritty it's
terrifying it's lonely
but poor adam west
hello
batman speaking poor adam west or
the original batman i don't know if you
guys have ever seen it but it's a corn
fest i know you'd employ your sneezing
powder
so i took an anti-allergy pill and it's
shameful
oh
better put five cents in the meter
and it just you know yes
you're gonna be okay he's gonna be
skinny he wears little underpants on the
outside of his stockings
it's frustrating that adam west who is
hands down one of the greatest acting
talents in the history of mankind was
not given the opportunity to play this
deep and dark character the producers of
this show wasted this icon's talents i
just can't understand why they would do
such an injustice to this character we
gotta figure out is there anyone in the
office that really knows batman i mean
there's one man
dean talk to us man i i don't know much
about batman i just have very strong
opinions
so maybe you can help enlighten us as to
what adam west deserves so let me spin
you guys a yarn about our dear batman
batman was created in 1939 in issue 27
of detective comics which actually dc
comics is detective comics comics
he carries a gun he like straight up
murders people oh and uh actually does
he kill yeah i thought batman didn't
kill oh no actually the first piers of
the joker batman kills the joker and
then later on they figured out a way to
bring him back but those early comics
didn't pull any punches they were very
dark so batman was born in the darkness
molded by it some say
it but then came the comics code
authority there was a book that came out
in the 50s called the seduction of the
innocent that argued comic books were
corrupting children simply by depicting
crime and violence it even singled out
the batman comic and argued that batman
and robin were in a gay relationship so
there was a real effort to make batman
super whitewashed and friendly for kids
no more killing all of the villains they
have like wacky plans instead of being
like serial killers and stuff this is
where you get all of these silver age
batman issues where he's wearing like
rainbow costumes and zebra print
costumes the 1966 batman film and the
series were a direct adaptation of those
silver age comics as a matter of fact
the creator of the show william dozier
had apparently never read a comic book
in his life and after skimming a few
issues he decided that the show should
be a comedy and essentially a parody of
the character are you a vocal group no
we're duly deputized officers of the law
you may return to your business citizen
but uh poor adam west he'll be forever
known as the lamest batman of them all i
think we can all collectively agree that
the comic book police did our boy dirty
yeah and we how dare you we gotta write
this wrong we all know that we peaked
when adam west was batman no one can
compete and we keep recasting we keep
trying again you're christian bales
i pick adam west you're robert
pattinson's and pick adam west you're
bruce what's his name who's the other
guy yeah
i just forgot the other guys i'm
thinking of bruce wayne but there's also
a guy who acted ben ben ben affleck i
already forgot about him
we're gonna pull that pure beautiful
adam west out of the past and bring him
into the present we're gonna keep adam
west relevant and shove his beautiful
innocent little body into the trailer
for the new batman it's time to make
adam west grit again we're gonna make
adam west grit again should we make hats
probably not i don't think we have to
make it yeah that's fine yeah let's skip
the hats yeah for our boy
touch our limbs show that you tear by
touching us
get over here
[Music]
no one's okay we should probably just
start let's just get started
[Music]
so with this video we're doing something
very different than all the other videos
we've done to this point we are using
nuke
previously quarters use after effects
for all of their compositing after
effects is great but the industry
standard for compositing is using the
foundry's nuke this is the standard in
hollywood and so we want to start
incorporating it here at corridor to
enhance the quality of the work that
we're putting out the main difference
between after effects and nuke is that
nuke is not layer based it's node based
after effects is great it's something
that i've used my entire life you can
make some really nice high-end stuff but
if your project gets too big you start
to run into some issues you're applying
effects to individual layers and then
you have to start pre-comping those
layers meaning you're combining all into
another layer so now all your effects
are hidden inside of that and you might
have pre-comps of pre-comps of pre-comp
so you have these nested sequences where
all your effects are hidden in layers
and layers of things that you cannot
possibly navigate in nuke what's so
great about it is since it's node based
everything is visible from the top level
almost like a bird's eye perspective
every single command that you want every
time you want to move its position or
move its scale or apply a glow you can
see all of it from a bird's eye
perspective right there and anything
that you change at the very top will
trickle down through all the wires to
the very bottom which makes doing a
large amount of shots like we have to do
in this week a lot more possible a lot
more doable and again that end product
is going to be
it's going to be high-end but it's going
to be hollywood baby
[Laughter]
i'm primarily like for my vfx work i use
nuke as my program of choice it's what
i'm most comfortable with and jordan
primarily uses houdini and for
compositing use after effects so this
project is a really great opportunity
for jordan to kind of get his little vfx
toesies wet and dip into that nuke
pipeline a little bit so we're going to
finish prepping our vfx side of things
well matt digs into the original adam
west batman movie so we can lock down
this edit let's do it
so the first step on our bat journey is
to find clips from our original batman
movie with adam west to possibly use uh
for vfx purposes or for sound bites all
of this serves to immerse our our old
adam west into a new modern trailer so
after i cut down the trailer i just kind
of went through and watched the movie
and there's a lot of ridiculous stuff in
here there's a whole battle between
batman and a shark for some reason i
mean this was before jaws so this is
like the original jaws oh there's a
moment where the penguin's in disguise
and no one believes this it's like the
worst disguise ever and he still makes
little penguin jokes i did find this
this awesome sequence of batman
pretending like he's drugged
and dancing like an egyptian
i think this moment we can put this
in that little hallway gunfight scene in
the new trailer that would just be so
funny if we just see batman dancing like
a fool and dodging bullets
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
this movie is
this movie's a lot this movie's a lot um
but i think i can rescue adam west from
his goofy campy prison and place him in
a serious
real movie for real adults
so we are underway right now with the
visual effects for our adam west batman
and the exciting part about this process
is that it's my first time in nuke and
fenner has lovingly and graciously
shown me the ropes right now i feel like
a a baby and fenner is raising this baby
to be a more helpful adult fenner has
entrusted me with this shot which is a
really fun one of the penguin colin
firth played by colin powell
played by colin mockery
who played the the penguin
but yeah the new penguin obviously is
turning around fearful of batman chasing
him and we need to put the old penguin
in so how do we do that right there's a
couple steps first thing we got to do is
we have to find a source
of footage of the old penguin from the
batman movie so we looked through the
archives and we came up with this it's a
penguin smoking a really long sig the
angle works well you know the the eye
direction isn't good but we can solve
that later so once we've got this done
we ran it through topaz video enhanced
ai which up rez's the footage that we
gave it from 720p all the way to 4k
adding a lot of detail so now all of a
sudden we can put these two together and
it won't seem so out of place so now we
are ready to roto out the head and
nobody likes roto that's the reality and
luckily we don't have to do that anymore
thanks to runwayml runwayml is an online
ai driven platform that has a very very
powerful roto tool literally two clicks
i clicked this footage two times and it
came up with this map for me again it's
not perfect i had to do some fine tuning
on the back end but it saved me a ton of
time we have a big problem here right
he's looking off to the right
the penguin in the movie is looking
camera left right what are you gonna do
i'll tell you what you're gonna do
you're gonna cut out his eyes it has to
be done
i overlaid our penguin here with freshly
cut eyeholes and he happened to line up
perfectly with the left eye of the other
penguin so this is actually the eye of
the actor from underneath it's still
made of penguin but this is the new
penguin's eyes in the old penguin's body
we're getting weird now
this eye is the same eye in both eye
sockets and it actually works pretty
well
and at that point you just need to
actually track the footage of the
penguin stick the head on do some roto
to bring back the foreground elements
and then it comes down to the
compositing and that's really the extent
of it you know it's a very quick shot
but overall i think it holds up quite
well i'm quite happy again i feel like
i've escaped maybe the little baby cage
don't know the technical term for that
but i call it the baby cage crib the
crib yes i call it a baby cage i don't
know
so i've escaped the baby cage
and i feel like i'm you know i'm still
kind of crawling but i'll take a few
steps before i fall
you're doing it
[Laughter]
dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyway back to work
so there's this one shot in the batman
trailer that i know we absolutely have
to do
to me this was really the most iconic
shot of the trailer and maybe of the
whole film for the batman because when i
saw this in the theaters i was just like
oh my god that's that's like one of the
cooler shots i've ever seen we thought
how funny would it be to bring in this
old 1966 batmobile and comp it into this
shot so what i did first is i just went
digging on the web there was like a five
dollar batmobile model super janky
looking but i did the trick so we've got
this guy here it had a little bit of
texture on it but i basically reshaded
the model just to so that we can get
that light interaction because there's
that big explosive light source
so then from there kind of hand animate
and match move the batmobile to the
actual 2022 batmobile again you can see
what we got out of the blender here this
is basically it it's nothing special
it's it's pretty janky looking honestly
this is my background as a compositor
you know working on feature films you're
not actually going to always end up with
assets that look good enough for the
movie so even if you get a render like
this you know the shot's got to go out
you got to do what you can to make it
work so the profile of the 1966
batmobile and the 2022 batmobile are
actually really similar they're both
based on muscle cars it actually made it
you know not too crazy to line these up
basic premise of comp is you have to
make sure all your color values are
matching your black levels like the
whole point of compositing is to make it
look like every single element every
single render any kind of asset you're
using in your shot you want to make it
look like it's been shot through that
actual camera lens once we're doing that
it really starts to sit within the shot
pretty nice looking final shot that i'm
really hoping will kind of be the
icing on the cake for this overall piece
so we've been working on a whole bunch
of other shots but this one shot of the
back copter that i did a couple days ago
is definitely one that i want to go back
to we're kind of playing up that gag
because it's pretty iconic you know
hilarious thing from the 1966 film
and i really found that the shots that i
had comped weren't holding up to the
rest of the piece we created especially
the batmobile stuff at the end that's
the one shot i really want to try to
step it up i couldn't find a model of
the 1966 back copter so i just went and
searched the bells of the internet and
managed to find a fairly decent fbx
brought this into blender real quick and
that's where i started to kind of hack
together
this back copter so i sculpted these
wings kind of tweaked some things on the
model and got it to a point where i was
like okay you know what this is gonna
hold up in the shot if you can get
something to the point where it looks
good enough when it's motion blurred and
out of focus then for me
that's probably gonna hold up so
basically we're able to now add this in
to some stock footage which you know
looks okay but it doesn't really look
like it sits within that batman movie
which is what we're really trying to do
here so looking at a shot from the
batman it's like crazy orange color
grading on there flared out lights we
get that anamorphic flaring so i
basically built out a little bit of a
setup here which basically brings us
that weird lens distortion that haloing
effect that we get that cat's eye bokeh
and it kind of sits it more within the
rest of the film and we get a pretty
nice result so i'm hoping that with this
extra little you know finishing pass on
the shots that will uh you know have a
really nice final edit here
[Music]
oh nick i think when we were working on
this batman video i think jordan
actually thinks he's batman now check
this out
master wine
good lord what are you doing in here you
want to tune in what are you doing
do you want to tell the uh fans about
puget puget systems can we trust them
yes we can yes these future systems have
been amazing for working on this project
they don't just sell from your
workstations no they do weigh more they
help you build it from the ground up
custom fit exactly what you need like a
bat suit with more wires a custom fit pc
tailored to perfection like alfred
taylor's my suits
my voice my voice is hurting she might
be a little bit crazy right now but he's
not wrong these puget systems are truly
amazing alfred why are you talking like
that oh god what happened here boys come
here come here what come here okay i'll
tell you i'll tell you some truths okay
puget systems literally increased my
simulation speed by 15 times i'm not
even joking about that i'm dead i'm
actually dead serious it's crazy i
literally went from a three-hour
simulation to like 15 minutes i don't
know if that math is right i actually
need some tea alfred t please
please please
please t
sure thing must delane
so
if you want to learn more go to
youtube.com or click the link down below
if you want to get your hands on one of
these sweet feasts that's exactly what i
was saying batman says the call to
action that's right pugetsystems.com or
just click the link that we placed below
this video
alfred clean up the wires
clean up the wires i'm gonna break my
neck my
honestly man please
please
plus we're going to nab so we're doing a
meetup at the puget booth so come say hi
on monday
have you been here the whole time the
entire time
honestly security's kind of lacking
what a week of cutting and watching
batman new and old our boys over here
have already finished vfx shots and i
can already plug them in their workflow
is insanely fast and i think we have a
cut that works super well but what i
feel like it really needs now is that
extra little bit of sauce and that comes
in the form of soundtrack a soundtrack
that incorporates the original batman
theme into a cinematic dark gritty
modern score and i think we can call
upon the talents of casey edwards to
design a score for us that will
incorporate that and let it ride
throughout the piece i think it's the
final step here to really tie this piece
together so i can't wait to hear what
casey has cooking up for us once i drop
that in i think we have a final piece
here that we can show everyone and i'm
super excited
[Music]
boys how do you feel how do you feel put
all this all this hard work into this
project and now finally you're about to
see it on the big screen i'm excited i
think we're both excited very you know
it's it's a long time in the making the
whole week and here we are i mean we
don't need to say anything else we're
ready to rock and roll
let's do it
abominable outlaws
i swear by heaven
i'll kill you all
all adds up to a sinister riddle
hello
batman speaking
[Music]
what kind of creature would gobble up a
bird and a tree
the penguin
how come batman doesn't dance anymore
you gracious with your presence
[Music]
to the batmobile
is
[Music]
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
[Applause]
west adam west adam west
[Applause]
[Music]
everything in this looks like an
alternate universe where this movie was
made like everything fits so nicely the
batmobile coming through the fire there
almost just looks like the original
footage i had to be like wait no
that's a different car for me the
profile shot of the of the battle feels
like super dope where you really realize
oh no hold on this is different once you
get to the actual batmobile it just gets
down to like this is awesome
looks like it's like legit yeah it makes
adam west about as cool as possible and
you know what actually that brings me to
my last question here
did we evade the comic book police
i think you guys did adam west proud i
think
i think you've overcome the censorship
of the 60s and placed adam
in his rightful place as the greatest
batman ever
give it up
you did it
yeah
i'm uh absolutely blown away by the nuke
workflow it made this so fast and
so effective and so like high level with
the final touches and finishes that you
can put on the back end with the film
grain and the glows and just the way
that it operates you know fenner was a
great teacher through this whole
experience the end product the fact that
that's done in a week still blows my
mind i have to shout out the score that
was custom made for this it was so so
cool casey edwards did this and he did a
freaking fantastic job of like really
cementing this as like a serious
super serious version of the original
batman yeah the way he tied in the old
school theme with the new theme yeah
like just when i first heard that i got
goosebumps by the way we have a crew
cuts episode that kind of goes into
depth into what casey does
uh for corridor so check that out on our
website which is corridor digital.com
this video actually exists as a
standalone on the main corridor channel
so check that out and pass it on some
friends if you're into that kind of
thing is it good is it believable is
this batman
i don't know subscribe to the channel
you gotta subscribe to the channel i'm
making over here you gotta subscribe
we're multiplying then subscribe to the
channel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]